hola muy buen día estuve revisando el
vídeo pasado y me di cuenta que en el
último problema había dos formas de
resolver ese problema y llegar a la
solución correcta así que decidí hacer
un mini vídeo contándote cómo podemos
llegar a la solución correcta de la
segunda forma seguramente alguien de
ustedes dijo un porqué salman khan no lo
hace por esta otra forma entonces se me
ocurrió que sería muy bueno repasar este
otro método para llegar a la solución
del problema número 14 estamos hablando
del problema número 14 y es que esta
solución quiero darte la porque tiene
que ver con algo que ya hemos aprendido
recordemos el problema el problema decía
si yo tengo la sucesión
3,9 a coma etcétera y además me dan que
la suma de los primeros cinco términos
vamos a ponerle así la suma de los
primeros cinco de los primeros cinco la
suma de los primeros cinco es es 605 es
605 entonces lo que me preguntaban era
cuánto valía y yo lo que quiero saber es
el valor de amd y bueno tal vez algunos
de ustedes recuerden esta fórmula tal
vez algunos de ustedes no recuerden esta
fórmula sin embargo cuando yo hablaba de
sucesiones geométricas podría encontrar
las sumas de los primeros n términos con
la siguiente expresión la suma de los
primeros en términos lo voy a poner así
la suma que depende de los primeros en
de términos esto es igual al término
inicial que por cierto en este caso vale
am que multiplica a la razón elevada a
la
esto -1 y a esto lo dividimos entre r
menos uno muy bien porque pongo esta
fórmula aquí porque si nosotros ya
sabemos que la suma de los primeros
cinco términos es 600 5 primeros no
primos o no dejen de echar esto esto no
es primos es primeros es 605 entonces
podemos sustituir de aquí
la suma podemos sustituir de aquí la
razón tenemos 5 términos y de aquí
podemos despejar el valor de amd
si nosotros recordamos esta suma que
tenemos aquí o en su dado caso el
problema está mucho más difícil creo que
es una buena herramienta para llegar a
la solución vamos a ver aquí llegamos la
suma de los primeros en eternos bueno la
suma de los primeros cinco términos es
entonces me va a quedar 605 esto es
igual a amd que es el primer término
justo lo que no sabemos
que multiplican a la razón elevada a la
n menos 1 cuál es la razón bueno porque
estamos multiplicando de aquí para
llegar acá de aquí para llegar acá lo
que hicimos fue multiplicar por 3 y si
te das cuenta esta es la razón porque de
aquí para llegar acá estamos
multiplicando por tres y de hecho eso
era justo lo que me decía el problema
entonces la razón es 3 elevada a la n
pero n es la cantidad de términos que
estamos sumando en este caso n vale 5 es
decir 3 elevado a la 5 esto menos 1 y
todo esto dividido entre 3 - 1 y si te
das cuenta lo único que hay que hacer de
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí es
obtener el valor de amd que es justo lo
que queremos y bueno
3 - 1 es 2 entonces este 2 lo voy a
pasar multiplicando al 605 y me queda 2
por 605 cuantos eso 605 por 2
esto me quedan 2 por 5 10 y lleva
nadal 2 x 6 12 mil 210 entonces mil 210
es exactamente lo mismo que am que va a
multiplicar a 3 a las 5 cuantos 3 a las
53 x 39 y en este momento estamos al
cuadrado si lo multiplicamos por 3 es 27
y vamos elevando al cubo entonces 27 por
esto es 81 y entonces estamos elevando a
la cuarta potencia y si a esto lo
multiplicó por 3 entonces llegó a 3 a la
quinta que es 3 por 1 33 por 8 24 243
entonces esto es lo mismo que 243 menos
1 243 menos 13 242 muy bien y ahora para
sacar el valor de amd va a ser igual a
1.210 entre 242 y cuantos esto vamos a
hacerlo por aquí 1210
entre 242 y cabe haber vamos a ver 5
veces 5 por 2 10 y llevamos una 5 por 4
20 y una que llevábamos 21 y llevamos 25
por 2 10 y 2 12 entonces cuando yo
arresto estos dos me queda 0 por lo
tanto el valor de amd es 5 queda justo
el valor que me había salido en el vídeo
pasado ya está aquí tenemos otra forma
de llegar a la misma solución nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo